[Music]
on today's show we talked to a newly
married husband who just found out his
wife has not been going to college for
the last three years like she told him
we also talked to a young new mom who
just lost her mom to cancer and she's
struggling with grief we talk to a man
who wants to be a better husband and
father stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john deloney show so glad you're here
i'm so glad you're here hope things in
your in your world are going all right
good great grand wonderful whatever i
hope it's going good on this show we
talk about relationships and mental
health and i don't know why i'm growling
i'm all excited i'm kind of freaked out
a little bit but before i get to the
freaked out uh if you want to be on the
show 1-844-693-3291
leave a message
and kelly will call you back
and by the way if kelly ever calls you
she loves it she loves it
when you have a joke ready when you
swear a lot or when you are um what else
you just start rattling off song lyrics
she loves those three things especially
is that fair
no
no
i disagree but um whatever so
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
ask
and what is happening
in the booth
we have the assistant to the regional
manager team back there
james is gone we got everybody's wearing
purple what are you doing james is gone
for like three days and kelly's cult is
already like everybody's wearing purple
and everybody's gonna be in it's what's
happening
it's the spelling bee today it's the
company spelling bee yeah
and all of the we're divided up into
floors so our floor is purple
and there's a green one and all sorts of
different colors and then at lunch we're
gonna go out and eat lunch and
it's unlike any other spelling bee
you've ever seen
just in case you're wondering yeah i
went to college and this is where i work
we have a uh company spelling me
with uh matching t-shirts
sometimes people think dylan i think you
work at a cult and on days like this i
think you are correct you are absolutely
correct you'll all look beautiful
i do have a purple shirt on my
my little desk in my little office area
and i will probably put it on at some
point today but i just want you all to
know i feel uncomfortable and weird and
i just needed that to be said out loud
y'all are beautiful handsome all the
things but i'm uncomfortable and i feel
like at any moment i could get murdered
so i'm probably going to call into the
show later on just
just from where i'm sitting
and
we have
zach pretending on the uh on the the
screens
it's good to see you oh dude you look
super a fish you only have uh
uh one ear on the headphones like you're
some kind of rapper
good call dude like a dj that's
incredible i'm learning how to do this i
don't i don't know what i'm doing
what's good for you is i don't enjoy i i
don't either it's awesome all right
let's go to uh david in san antonio
brother what's up david how are we doing
man
hey dr john i'm doing good how about
yourself we're good brother how can i
help man what's up
um so i guess i have a relationship
question um
so i just got married to my girlfriend
of five years uh this past march hey
hold on one second hold on a second yeah
anytime somebody says
i guess i have a relationship issue
or a question usually that means it's
big is this big i'm trying to get my
frame of mind around it
yeah yeah i'd say it's pretty big um all
right let me switch gears here i've got
a team full of
purple wearing t-shirt people staring at
me so let me get my my head screwed on
straight all right so we got a big one
here go for it brother yeah what's up
so yeah so we've been together for about
five years and we just got married um
but i just found out uh pretty recently
at the beginning of summer that
uh well so we were both in school and so
i thought um so for like the past three
years she's kind of been pretending to
go to school and kind of be being
dishonest about
actually going to school and so i kind
of feel a little bit betrayed i guess
okay so she's kind of been
kind of been not going to school and
kind of been dishonest and you feel a
little bit betrayed so let me back out a
little bit
so your girlfriend's told you for three
years she's going to college she's been
lying to you for three years and you are
pissed off and heartbroken is that a
better way to say that
yeah yeah
so how what's you been doing for three
why she's been lying to you what you
been doing for three years did she think
after y'all got married you wouldn't
find out what was that what was the game
plan here yeah i
i don't know and that's what i'm having
a hard time like understanding um i know
she
she came from like a family i don't know
if this is me like trying to like
re or rationalize it but uh she came
from a family where it's hard to like
share things you're a hundred percent
rationalizing it you don't lie to
somebody for three years about going to
college where's she been going all day
is she like faking writing papers and
assignments and stuff
yeah that's pretty much what was going
on um and i saw the red flags bro that's
a long term that's a long term deception
yeah
what red flags did you see
i never heard of that professor she's
like oh no it's cool man just adjunct
like what was happening so she like to
hardly go to school and or like
like she was like never
yeah and
it was like uh hardly any homework
assignments that kind of thing and i was
like what school are you going to i
would love to go there but yeah so
so you've known to
yeah um
why did you go along with this for three
years
oh well so we have a daughter together
okay um
could care less why did you go along
with this for three years
i i don't know
what made you all of a sudden decide to
care about this
well i i i cared the whole time um i
just chose to trust her
she was pretty good at hiding i guess
but you've known something was off for a
long time though right
right yeah
so how did you find out
i'm fascinated by this three years man
that's a long game in three years it's
not like
she was cheating on you with somebody
else for three years
and she could just break that off
at the end of year four
they give you this dope thing called a
bachelor's degree
and so it's like this had this had like
an expiration date on it this scam she
was running
right and that's kind of
like i that's kind of what i had in the
back of my head i was like how are you
going to do this part like kind of
uh and sure enough when that time came
around so in may
uh when she was supposed to graduate um
that's when she finally came queen and
that was two months after we got married
so she dude she played the graduation
car like all like yeah i can't wait to
graduate in may all that
um
kind of uh so there's a there's a cup
there's a couple other things that um
she was making it uh sound so she's in
the military and she was making it sound
like
she wouldn't be able to go to the
graduation because she would get
deployed or like she would get uh
something about going to training or
something like that sure so
yeah
so how can i help man what's your
question
well so
i like i do want to
like i don't want to just
like you know and our relationship like
i want to work through it but i'm having
trouble like from
for myself i guess just uh
getting like
getting over that hurt i
guess yeah so
um
let me back out what else does she lie
to you about
um
to me like
nothing
not i like nothing big like that she has
she has what else
i mean they were
just like you called me bro
yeah i i know
she like i know she like
lie like she lied to
like her mom pretty much the whole time
she grew up
and i knew about those lies
as far as why she's told me i don't like
i don't really think there's
very many
so that's the problem
is when you play a three-year con on
somebody that you're marrying
even to the point that you are
pretending that you're a graduate i mean
this didn't have an end to it and so
what i'm trying to show walk you through
is this isn't a normal lie
right this didn't have a this wasn't
just gonna
turn into a mist and hopefully be in the
past right and this isn't a matter of
you all met at some bar somewhere and
she told you she was in the fbi
and
at some point she had to just come clean
right this isn't like that
this is
a level of deception that feels
pathological to me
yeah
does that make sense yeah yeah and
that's kind of
like this is a strong idea yeah all
lying's a problem
but that this is one that felt so long
game and so calculated and the
calculation was so absurd
this isn't it's it's a level of
deception that is feels clinical to me
that's why i ask you this is a this is a
an mo when somebody does this
yeah right and so you mentioned she lies
to her mom all the time probably about
benign stupid stuff right
yeah yeah for no reason and so if i'm
you i'm questioning
everything
who have you dated who have you been
with are you even in the military is
this my kid is this i would i would
question everything
which then makes it really hard right to
just go grab tacos one night right
yeah
so when you found out about this was
there what was the response was it like
i know i'm so sorry let's just go out to
dinner i mean what was the response was
it a meltdown
uh from from me or like my response both
well i mean um
yeah it was
it was pretty it was pretty rough it was
a rough couple weeks and i think
like i tried to work through it um and
that made me like it took a strain on
like my relationships with like my
daughter with her with my mom i was
getting like i didn't like who i was
becoming okay or i was just
kind of taking it out in the wrong
places you know yep
and here's the thing in all this you got
hurt and you got buzzed bad
but you can't turn into an idiot over
this
right you still got to retain
dignity and respectability you got to
treat her with respect even though she
has absolutely not treated you with
dignity you've still got to take the
high road is that right
right yeah that's i guess i'm having
trouble with that
that's a choice brother that is separate
and apart you're hurt and you're hurt
bad and you should be
and you just man you double down on a
woman you've known for five years and
you didn't know her
everything about everything the rug has
been pulled out on you right i get that
everything has been shaken like a snow
globe in your world
and that's
heartbreaking man
not to mention are you in the military
too
uh no i'm not okay but do you run with
that crew
do you all have any connections together
uh no so i just i graduated pretty
recently like a year ago and i started
working during the whole coveted season
okay five yeah okay
i was gonna say add the added stress on
top of what's happening with the
military right now it's tough it's a
tough season yeah yeah
and that stuff's gonna make its way hold
your daughter oh she's three and a half
okay so you got three and a half year
old which is chaos for any all that to
say
yeah i need you to promise me
you're gonna treat your daughter with
dignity and respect you're gonna treat
your wife with respect regardless of if
this marriage doesn't work out you're
still gonna be a person in character
will you make that commitment
yeah good
thank you
we need you your daughter needs you your
community needs you don't take this out
on your mom don't take this out on a
little girl
now i know it's easier said than done i
know that
do you have some guys in your life that
are trustworthy
that are aren't idiots and that you can
call
and they'll come over
yeah i think so okay you got to let them
in
and not in a whining about your wife
kind of way but say hey dude everything
i or the whole sidewalk i walk on has
been blown up
so here's the situation your marriage
dude um
has your wife giving you the whole i
promise this is the only thing and i
don't know what happened and it just got
too big and i couldn't do it i'm so
sorry but let's just move on is that
what you got
yeah pretty much
i think whenever
like
like i think whenever it first started
or at least from what she told me she
said like
she was planning on like
uh re-enrolling in the school and then
um and then like just month after month
went by and then it just never happened
and she just kept it going and then it
just
like she couldn't do it anymore she
couldn't keep it going anymore well yeah
but
and like she couldn't keep it going
anymore because she's supposed to
graduate
supposed to end
right
right so do you want to stay married to
her
i do yeah okay
here's what's got to happen asap
number one you've got to recognize that
y'all are gonna have to
pull apart what you all have and rebuild
something completely new
and
i am hopeful and optimistic that there's
not other boyfriends there hasn't been
other deception that she's been who she
says she is except for this one thing i
don't think that's the case but i hope
so
and then there's gonna have to be
some sort of marriage counseling
like starting tomorrow
um she's actually so she's at basic
training right now um so haven't i when
did she get out
uh probably another month or so okay so
what you've got is a month to go see
somebody and get your head squared away
because you're hurting right
right so i want you to start today make
a call today there is a bajillion great
counselors in san antonio you can go to
betterhelp.com get a discount on
internet counseling right you can see
somebody on your on your computer at
your house
i don't care what you got to do but you
got to go see somebody and say i just
had the rug pulled out from under me and
i need to know what to do next
i got three old little girl here i've
got a woman that i love but someone who
has lied to me
systemically and pathologically for
three years
and what that person will do is help you
work through your anger and your
frustration and your pissed off and your
fear and all those things and then give
you some
some next steps and the next steps are
gonna have to be a
there will never be lying in this home
ever again
not over what's for dinner not over what
did you have for lunch not over big
things little things this would be a
truth telling home and there may have to
be some practice on that your wife may
have to practice that because
i don't think she's ever told the truth
and she may have a lot of personal work
to do too right right yeah
but you've got a month head start on
this and that's really remarkable
because you don't like who you've become
too right
yeah and
ever since like she kind of
uh went to basic training i've kind of
been realizing like
like i was like in this
i don't know just cycle that was just
never ending and
i've kind of gotten a chance to be
myself again i don't know if that makes
sense absolutely
absolutely that's why i'm convinced
brother and i don't mean to be negative
debbie downer here i'm convinced there's
other things and i'm convinced that you
know there's other things you don't want
to face it
and whether those other things are
you've just completely shifted who you
are to try to make this weird
relationship happen because you have a
beautiful little girl and you do love
this woman
and you finally got to breathe for the
first time in a month and you've been
able to go
i can't ignore this stuff anymore
on top of the big blowup that's my guess
i may be way out to lunch man and maybe
i'm putting dark seeds in your head i
don't mean to be doing that
something else is here and i think you
know that
but i do appreciate the one important
thing you said
i'm just looping and looping and i gotta
do something different yes yes
so glad you called today you reach out
to a counselor in your area or today you
reach out to a mentor and say i gotta
tell you everything
today you get with somebody that you
trust and you say i'm gonna tell you
everything because i don't know what to
do next
and it's gonna start with you getting
back taking care of your body and your
head and your mind and your daughter and
calling your mom and saying i'm so sorry
i did not like who i become i'm gonna be
different and then you're gonna get some
tools
that call starts today
and then david you've got a long road of
rebuild ahead of you can it happen
absolutely absolutely
is gonna be hard yep is she gonna have
to be all all in
yep she is
you have to rebuild a lot of trust it's
going to take a long time
is it going to be worth it i think so i
think she's worth it if you think she's
worth it
your daughter's especially worth it
but you can't brush over this can't come
back from basic training be like oh it's
all cool it's cool it's good it's not
gonna be how it works
you have to excavate everything and
rebuild it all
[Music]
you got this david make the call today
we'll be right back on the dr john
dalona show
hey what's up this delony let's talk
about getting a good night's sleep it's
important for your physical health your
mental health your relation health for
your sanity you name it sleep is
important if you're not sleeping good
one of the first questions i want you to
ask is do i need a new mattress
here's how you tell are you tossing and
turning all night because you can't get
comfortable are you waking up in the
middle of the night burning hot or in
the morning does your back hurt if you
have any of these issues you may need a
new mattress
check out dreamcloud it's a mattress i
have in my own house you will love it
and they're currently running their
biggest offer of all time
400 bucks in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount only for delony
listeners that's a total of 650 bucks in
accessories and savings visit
dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get a new mattress shipped to
your house today and you can enjoy 650
bucks in savings that's
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code
d-e-l-o-n-y
all right we're back let's go to kira in
sin jose california kira what's going on
hey dr john how are you
i'm rocking on man how are you
i'm pretty good very cool so what's up
how can i help yeah
um
so my question i lost my mom about a
year ago to cancer wow
what kind of cancer
pancreatic cancer oh
quick and very awful very fast
yeah very painful pretty
not fun way to go
um it sounds so soft so
yeah yeah so it was kind of it was fast
it was um
shocking and then
so kind of in the so that was
also kind of right when
kovid was in the thick of things um you
know so
visiting was hard it was kind of scary i
work in healthcare
so a lot of just
worrying about
um everything exposing
everything yeah
so then
yeah so kind of in the middle of that
i
found out i was pregnant
which was
um also a shock i had been told for a
long time that i would not be able to
have children
surprised all right surprise
and what better time to find out you're
pregnant than when your mom's slowly
passing away and there's a pandemic
going on and you work in health care
yeah
yeah so
a lot going on
hey hold on for a second have you just
stopped and went
i
that's a lot right
no no
not like um you haven't
it's a lot
a lot
yeah um okay so where are we now
babies baby here
so yeah so baby's here baby's doing
great he's five months old that's fun
what's his name
very oakley oh beautiful i love it
okay so you got a five month old
yeah five month old my mom let's see so
she passed away in october
he was born in march um
it would have been her first grandkid
you know so she's uh
that hurts um so march before so
so he oh so he came just a few months
after she passed away yeah okay yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah and so
my question i guess is just
so now i'm kind of at that point where
i'm moving past that
early grief um
like just kind of the shock of it all
and kind of just realizing like what
i've actually lost um what my son has
lost
you know it's like this is the rest of
my life she's not going to be here yeah
tell me what it feels like to say that
out loud
it hurts
what does that mean
i mean honestly it just feels hopeless
um
just kind of empty like like what now
um
you know it's
it's like all i have a question and i
don't know who to ask
you know and it's like questions that i
didn't know
you know when she was sick it was you
know we kind of had some conversations
like
if there's anything
you
want to ask me like now is the time to
ask me
um
but you don't think of something in the
moment you know it's like you think of
it later when it's too late yeah
and you're supposed to be able to text
your mom about diarrhea and rashes and
what diaper right you're supposed to
yeah
you know it's like
i was
one of those people who called my mom
every day you know it's like
we had a very good relationship um so it
just hurts so your mom was awesome huh
yeah she was
she was yeah she would have been a
really great grandma too
um
so my dad is
i mean like my dad and i have a very
good relationship too um
but he's obviously also going through a
big trauma yeah
um
and hey he's he's your dad
and yeah it's different yeah he doesn't
he may be the best guy in the world
he's never carried a kid right yeah and
there's something about like i just want
my mom
yeah um and kind of on top of that he
had a traumatic brain injury a couple of
years ago
and so he's
it's like
he changed after that
um so he's still
like my dad he's still there but his
personality is not the same yeah um
and then after this it's just kind of
like one more thing
so
it's just hard
so i don't know you know do you do me a
favor
take as deep a breath as you can and
just hold it for a second
three yeah two and then let it all out
say these words out loud
this
is
this is
there's a period there
and it feels hollow and hopeless
and after
seven months nine months of
oh my gosh mom's sick to pancreatic
cancer to hey she's got three months to
hey i'm having a baby too now you've got
a five-month-old and you said it you
know
you you said it so great
the smoke is starting to clear on the
chaos
and now there's this reality right
it's kind of like you get by on
adrenaline a cortisol for a year and all
of a sudden
you wake up and the tornado the sun came
up the next day and the tornado came
through and there's no more house and
now you're just looking at the yard and
i don't know what to do now
yeah the first part of that is
that moment this is
and that's the hardest heartbreaking
you're there right
it feels hopeless you love that little
kid and you just want
to have that picture of your mom holding
him
and you should have that picture and
you're not
right yeah so what does grief look like
for you right now do you have a do you
have a gang do you have a crew do you've
got
to look like i mean i think
that's part of it is where
i believe my husband and i has moved
every year for the last six years
yeah it's hard when i
when i went on my
maternity leave from work
there was a
like an acquisition and
everybody i knew at work quit
um you know so it's like i go back and
don't know anybody
so we're
yeah just trying to
plug in somewhere has been really hard
with coping too so hard yeah
so let me um
can i give you a couple of ideas
yeah
yeah
um
you may have done this maybe not i say
this all the time and
um even i start to roll my eyes sometime
but it's so healing
if you haven't already
um
start a 30 day i'm going to write my mom
a letter every day
yeah just you
and you can put it in what i would do if
i was you is i'd get a special journal
i'd probably overpay for one go buy like
a nice leather journal
and i want those letters to be something
that you pass along to your son
so that he can see him
one of the greatest gifts you're going
to give him in the future
is a record of how my mom loved
how my mom grieved
how my mom took care of me and some of
her darkest moments
and it's going to be hard to remember
that kind of stuff in five years and 10
years and 20 years
a raw journal of the season i lost my
mom
will be a transformative gift for your
for generations right it'll be a legacy
gift
it's one of those meaning making things
and in this journal you'll probably be
heartbroken you'll probably be mad at
your mom for getting sick you'll be mad
at your dad because he's different
you'll all those things are going to be
real and raw and painful but what
they're going to do is they're going to
give you right now that's all sitting
right on top of your heart
and the more you write it the more
there's becomes this tiny little
distance
between that hurt those waves
and you
and right now it feels like it's all you
and it is yeah but you're going to give
yourself some space there and then maybe
after 30 days you go to once a week
letter
and i want you to continue to reach out
to ask those questions
in this journal
mom he's got a weird rash i need some
help and you're not here
right yeah mom he will not
stop asking for snacks
help me
or
uh he's five months old and husband's
already like so are we gonna start to
you know
mom yeah
what i write i want all that stuff
written down
and
she'll still be with you in those
moments
the second thing is this
give me one quick thing that your mom
loved
what brought her joy what was her
mission in life
um
i mean she
she worked in
healthcare too and just
i mean her patients just loved her um
she
you know i still get
random little facebook messages from
former patients of hers and
um i think she really just changed a lot
of people's lives
so here's a cool thing
as you're as you're able to and it's
going to feel like you're panning back
from a picture
the grief right now it feels like you're
at in the ocean and you're treading
water over time it will feel like you're
walking through a creek
it's always gonna be wet right but it
will feel less overwhelming it'll feel
less
um like you're not gonna make it through
the next moment okay
you're gonna find these seasons of
meaning making these moments where
i'm gonna write every patient of hers
that i ever heard just let them know
that they blessed my mom too
or i'm gonna begin to make little
bracelets what's your mom's name
savannah i'm gonna make little bracelets
that says savannah cares and i'm gonna
give them to all my patients and let
them know
there's a legacy of care in my family
and i'm gonna take care of you or if you
are dealing with pediatrics and you can
tell a mom or a dad whose kid is sick
and they're scared i'm going to give you
this
bracelet with my mom's name on it it's a
reminder that my whole family has always
cared about you guys right and it
becomes these moments of ways you can
honor your mom and make meaning of your
mom and at the same time
and this is the hardest one you can let
her go
yeah and that will be seasons of taking
her clothes to donation places that will
be saying we don't need every other
piece of furniture that will mean we
right as you work through some of those
things what are the things that are
meaning making
what are the things that are important
and what are things we're going to let
mom go
all right i'm going to let her go and
that's not a thing you do today that's
the thing you do over time
and the final thing here please please
please
you are exhausted
you've got some knuckle-headed husband
he's probably awesome i'll give you that
um
a five-month-old
and a dad who's dealing with his own
please
trauma
do what you can to get connected in your
community
yeah you cannot do this by yourself
and that's not a thing to like guilt on
to be like well i got another chore to
do today i gotta make out with this guy
i gotta feed a five five-month-old and
now i gotta go make a friend it's not
like that but kind of what kind of it is
right
um please go get involved in a local
church go get with a mom's group or a
grief group
or a
lost my mom from cancer i guarantee you
there will be a group there in san jose
i guarantee it join a jogging group or
something
but get a crew
okay
yeah
walking through this by yourself is is
not tenable you can't do it you can
but it's gonna be hard to heal and we're
looking at legacy now
but i want tonight to be the night you
go get some silly overpaid priced fancy
leather journal or so i don't know if
you like i don't know what you put on
things
um sunshine's or i don't know unicorns i
don't care whatever some stamped cool
leather thing
um and make your first letter tonight
and it can just start with mom i miss
you and i need you here you're not here
and it might be a short letter it might
be a really long one but commit to 30
days
to writing your mom letters if you're a
gangster
and you're from san jose so maybe if
you're a gangster
you can read these to your husband
grief demands a witness you can read
them to him
maybe not maybe not
but if you did it'd be cool and maybe he
misses your mom too maybe he needs to
get a journal also you see i'm just i
miss
my mother-in-law he'll be one of seven
or eight people who've ever uttered that
sentence in all of world's history but
he might right he might really miss her
our hearts are with you i'm so sorry for
your loss
so sorry for the healing you gotta do so
sorry that you're
um your little boy's gonna grow up
without grandma
this is
what's next is where you're gonna shine
the light where you can honor your mom
make meaning of this senseless loss
where are you gonna begin to turn the
lights on find the sunshine find beauty
we're with you we'll be right back on
the dr john the wounded show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you it's why i
wrote this small direct and personal
book called redefining anxiety in this
book i discuss what anxiety is what it's
not and how you can get back on the road
of being whole and well listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndeloney.com and
get your copy of redefining anxiety
today
and we're back hey let's go to
uh tony in rochester new york what's up
tony
hey thank you for taking my call um i
don't want a stereotype but you realize
tony's the
most new york name possible that's
incredible
thank you
i needed a tony from new york today i'm
glad you called what's up brother how
can i help
um i own a construction company and i'm
having trouble just like disconnecting
from work and being me and it's
i really don't remember who i was prior
to this
oh man tell me about that is it blown up
is it just gone bananas
yeah i i do very well um
i have there's six of us total so i'm
just always working working right now
we're just months and months out and
it's just
all i do is think about work and like i
never can kind of be present in the
moment and
it's struggling with like marriage i
have a
toddler she's almost two um so it's just
hard to
like i remember when i worked for
someone else i didn't i just came home
and i lived my life but now
my life is i'm kind of like defined by
my business every time i see people it's
oh i was work going and i say the same
thing every time busy
i'm not i don't know where i am anymore
really
so man
you're one of the most self-aware men
i've ever talked to
like it usually takes 15 counseling
sessions to get to that what you just
said
that's incredible
tell me about i'm in
i've been in a bunch there you go so um
tell me about your wife how long you
been married tell me about her
we've been married for four years we've
been together for
i believe nine years now she's awesome
yeah i love her a lot and
she told me the other day that
all like all kind of like our issues and
like i've changed since i started a
business
and she's right right probably
probably or yeah yeah she's right yeah
yeah she's right
so um how much you make in a a year
what's your take home going to be
a lot um
over 100
maybe close to two okay
what about last year
i think i think it was like 150. okay
what about the year before
probably under 100 okay
what's enough what's the goal line here
i don't know
um
you got a picture in your head what's
the goal line
well i don't know if i want to go bigger
if i just want to stay where i am like
when you i was thinking about this the
other day you open up a restaurant okay
like i run a restaurant that's where i'm
gonna be either i'm gonna franchise i'm
not gonna franchise like expand but with
with me i can have at a crew take away a
crew do i want to go big or not there's
just so many possibilities like what
kind of work do i want to do
what field do i want to be in
i i don't truly know
at first i wanted to just go big and
when i went big i got up to like 10 guys
i was like well this is a lot of work
it's a lot yeah yeah
and if you're really good at
construction and you're really good at
bidding and you're good at managing
project projects
that's a whole different skill set than
trying to navigate 10 crew members and
they're crazy lives and are they going
to show up and they're late in their
flat tires and their marriage drama and
all that
so
you're trying to figure out your
business blew up you're clearly good at
what you do clearly i mean you're good
at it you're talented at it and that's
awesome
have you asked the question what kind of
dad do i want to be
what kind of husband do i want to be and
then you let those answers inform your
business
i don't think i've asked myself that
specifically but i thought of that i
don't want
i don't want to use words
put a picture in my head
of the dad you want to be
i wanted to be the dad that i didn't
have someone who's there and present and
what does that mean what does that mean
they're impressed those are just like
those are out of a hallmark card there
and present paint me a picture of it
just involved with like just ah like
like an actual picture
an actual picture i'm gonna be the guy
who picks my my son or daughter up from
soccer practice mom's gonna have to get
her there because i'm at work but i'm
gonna be the guy that picks him up i'm
gonna be the guy that has a little bit
too short of shorts on on saturday
morning it's freezing cold but i'm out
there watching the soccer game cheering
like mad and i don't even i don't even
know what's happening like paint me a
picture
yeah i want to be
there for like every big moment of her
life just
killing it really so listen listen she's
going to school events or anything just
being there and
spending time with her and growing with
her
so here's what i want you to do and i
want you to do this with your wife
because it'd be hard especially your dad
sucked
uh yeah he kind of gave up on us and my
mom died when i was like 3.
so here's what you're dealing with
you're dealing with the right heart
and not even the right heart an
incredible heart tony
but you don't have a picture of what
this looks like and when you don't have
a picture of what this looks like it's a
lot of platitudes and here's what those
platitudes become never enough
you will miss soccer games and you will
miss a play every once in a while
because you're running a business and
you're working your butt off and you're
providing for your family it's gonna
happen
and so when you have expectations like i
just want to be there for her for every
major moment
that's a noble idea
but it's it's going to set you up to
always feel like a failure because you
can't be there for everyone
my dad was an amazing
guy and
every major dance that i can remember
one of my neighborhood dads had to tie
my tie
because my dad was out
doing awesome stuff
do i regret it do i hate him no man he
was working hard and i never for one
second doubted they loved me and i got
to make some great relationships with
some of the neighborhood dads i just
grew up in that kind of neighborhood
that every like i was getting parented
by 20 different parents growing up
but it's still to this day like the joke
is man i
mike stewart tied my tie randy fox tied
my ties before major dances and stuff
because my dad was outside does that
make sense so here's the thing i want
you to speak very specifically and then
this is what it might sound like
i want to be a dad who has the entire
soccer schedule and i'm going to make
five out of the seven games
and if they're on saturdays i'm never
gonna miss them ever i'm gonna i'm gonna
pay somebody to be on call for those
saturday mornings and it may cost me a
thousand bucks because there may be a
pipe that burst on one of the set on one
of the
um construction construction zones that
we're working on
um but he's gonna go fix it because i'm
not gonna miss that soccer game
and then the other side of it is there's
gonna be some games i miss
and i'm gonna give myself grace on those
because my daughter knows i love him
knows i love her i'm gonna read a book
every night of the week to my daughter
every single day i will read a book i
will hug my daughter for 30 seconds
every day
so what i'm saying is i want you to
begin to paint pictures not use words
because you my brother are changing
family trees
you are changing legacy i'll even dare
to say your road is harder than mine
because i had a picture of what an
awesome dad looks like
you don't so you are painting something
new does that make sense
yeah cause like right now i just kind of
well all i know is like to provide and
i'm trying to that's why i provided them
well
here's what's gonna happen
that goal post is always gonna move on
you
it will never not move on you because
there's always gonna be a nicer private
school they could go to or you could get
him a bmw instead of a crappy corolla
for wait right you know what i mean like
that goal supposed to always move until
you sit down with your wife and then
i want you to sit down and say this kind
of husband i'm going to be
and this is what this is going to look
like on a day-to-day basis
so in my house tony i asked and this is
25 years of doing it wrong
i asked my wife we've been dating 25
years we've been married 19.
how can i help today
what does your picture of today look
like what do you need from me this week
and that's not romantic it's not sexy
but it's awesome
does that make sense
and then i backfill my profession from
there
i back work it comes after i decide what
kind of husband i'm gonna be now i'm
about to hit the road in the next few
months i'm gonna be gone a lot
and so we've sat down and have calendar
meetings every week we have done set
some dates on the calendar when we're
gonna go out we've got some dates when
we're gonna we're gonna go have a
weekend together when i'm home for a
week whatever um i had to put some
hunting trips some special trips on the
calendar with me and my son so we don't
lose that i mean my daughter but so i've
had to be hyper intentional about drop
making sure those pictures are going to
be that way and i know it come december
i'm going to be exhausted i know i am
and that's all right man
but we're being intentional and we're
being very clear about what this is
going to look like what success will
look like and what failure will look
like does that make sense
yeah so you're saying basically if i set
if i figure out draw a picture of where
i want my family left to be and where i
want to be as a husband and father and
also
where i want my business to be
it will help me those things i won't
focus so much on the business and i'll
focus more on what comes first and
rather than it will but it's going to
let you when you are in the business
you're going to be all in
so when i'm at work i'm not worried like
i wonder do i need to come get my son
today do i i don't have to worry about
that i know exactly where i need to be
afterwards and so when i'm here at work
i am a thousand percent in
growing this thing making it big taking
speaking engagements i'm gonna miss a
lot of stuff this fall i know i am
and i've already put some stuff on the
calendar not to make up because i don't
have to make things up
but just so i can continue to be the
husband and dad that i said i wanted to
be
and you have that exact heart if not
more
the challenge you have is you've got a
bunch of energy going 5 000 different
directions
and so what i want you to do is to sit
down and be hyper intentional about i
want to be this kind of dad
i want to be this kind of husband i want
to
let those inform i want to be this kind
of leader i want to have this kind of
construction dude brother you can have
the biggest construction company in the
state of new york
and you're going to have three or four
incredible senior associate vice
presidents who run things because you're
going to go home and get that game
you're going to take your kids
disneyland does that make sense
yeah yeah i just got to figure out what
i wanted what i want to get to and where
i want to be that's right but listen to
me the key here is don't use words use
pictures
because you're going to say things like
i want to be a super present husband i'm
and you're going to look at your wife
and you're going to have a tearful
moment you're going to say i'm going to
be the dad that is always here i'm going
to be the husband that always shows up
and she's going to say oh it's so great
and show up for her is going to mean
you're there at 4 30 every day
and show up for you means
two or three days a week i'm not home
till 8 o'clock because i'm leaving i'm
leaving the site
but a couple days a week i'm at home and
we're gonna we're gonna watch a tv show
together
and so what a picture gets you is gets
everybody on the same page
so when you say i'm gonna i'm gonna be
that kind of dad here's exactly what
that will look like
i'm going to make most of the games
or this particular hey honey we got a
new building it's a multi-million dollar
project i'm going to miss a lot of games
this year and that means in the mornings
i'm going to do long hugs i'm gonna do
bedtime when i can i'm gonna do weekend
duty does that make see what i'm saying
there we're painting pictures of what
this stuff's gonna look like and that
way you're on the same page with your
daughter and any other kids to come
you're on the same page with your spouse
and most importantly you're on the same
page with you
because now you're not just running this
endless race
of just trying to be somebody that your
dad wasn't trying to be that parent that
you're when your mom passed away
no i got a clear picture and i'm running
towards that
and then you can hit that man and then
when you're at work oh my gosh you're
going to crush work because you're going
to be all in i want to be this kind of
leader i want to be this kind of boss i
want to be this kind of
um when my name when my company takes a
job we're gonna have this kind of
reputation cause i'm gonna lean into
that
and then when i'm at home you can talk
to me tomorrow guys
because i love you guys but i love my
wife and my little girl more y'all have
to shake that off call tom he's on call
bye guys
you're gonna find out
every ship in your harbor is gonna rise
when you say this is this is me being
intentional what a stud tony
you've made my day better brother i'm so
grateful for the call and to all the
dads out there who feel like they're
running 500 different different
directions either i just lost the job
that mattered to me or my job exploded
underneath me i don't know what to do
and i feel like i'm not being the
husband i might be in the wife i'm not
being the dad
but start with pictures
start with this is what it's going to
look like when it's enough this is what
it's going to look like
when i can breathe this is what it's
going to look like today when today is
done
and then i can go home and put my feet
up it's going to be good
and go tell your wife today tony changes
today tony from new york changes
and we're gonna make new pictures
together it's gonna be awesome thank you
so much for your call brother
all right as we get to the end of the
show whose is this one
hindens
so zach rolls in here let me get this
right wearing his uh purple cult shirt
and he is practicing as the assistant to
the regional manager over here
and he's gonna call the shots on the
song of the day
and it's a good one
i do love drew holcomb and the neighbors
you're welcome
[Laughter]
kelly just put it out there zach's not
gonna last very long
but it's cool
wow
off the 2017 souvenir record zach
actually i love drew holcomb he's
awesome his wife ellie she's incredible
great songwriter good community member
here in nashville
and you did a good job so you're welcome
you're welcome
you should put that other cover your ear
up with the other headphone you look
ridiculous there you go now you're now
we're back
off the 2017 souvenir record good man
drew holcomb in the neighbors
songs wild world and it goes like this i
don't know about you but i like to tell
the truth but the truth seems to change
every tuesday when i watch the news man
it just gives me the blues no one
listens just on a mission to hear their
own voice true preach it it's a wild
world we're all trying to find our place
in it it's a wild world and no one seems
to understand it it's a wild world but
there ain't no way i'm gonna quit it
love is all we've got to give away drew
holcomb yes sir right here on the dr
john dolone show
[Music]
you